manger de la viande fait partie des
habitudes alimentaires dans de nombreux
pays dont le Canada
et avec une population mondiale en
croissance la demande pour les produits
carnés augmente aussi créant une
pression accrue sur les terres
l'agriculture intensive et la
surconsommation sont des causes majeures
de la perte de biodiversité et rappelle
plusieurs ONG en feu de cestum
ici alors qu'on négocie chaque phrase et
virgule avec soin plusieurs pays voient
l'importance d'y inclure une mention à
l'effet que l'on doit s'attaquer à
réduire l'empreinte mondial des régimes
alimentaires et à la surconsommation or
quelques pays si opposent de grands
producteurs de boeuf dont le Paraguay
l'Argentine et sans surprise selon
certains le Canada
la réaction secteur agroalimentaire des
protéines animales au Canada lorsqu'on a
eu le nouveau guide alimentaire si on a
un libellé qui qui s'en va vers
on doit réduire de façon significative
notre consommation de protéines animales
et consommer des protéines végétales
c'est sûr que ça va causer un certain
émoi
le Canada produit 2% du boeuf consommé
sur le globe puis le Québec et le
troisième exportateur mondial de port
certains croient que l'absence de mesure
d'aide au secteur de l'agriculture
explique pourquoi le Canada ne peut pas
appuyer un texte qui vise spécifiquement
l'assiette des Canadiens ça implique des
changements et les changements sont
souvent synonymes de résistance et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il soit
accompagné d'aide financière et
accompagner de ressources également sur
le terrain pour aider les agriculteurs à
réaliser une transition qui ne soit pas
qui ne les pénalise pas le gouvernement
canadien se défend en affirmant que la
proposition est redondante simplement
parce que dans les objectifs de
développement durable des Nations Unies
on a déjà un objectif sur la production
et la consommation durable et nous
sommes en train d'insérer ça dans les
lois canadiennes c'est dans la nouvelle
stratégie de développement durable du
gouvernement du Canada on trouve
simplement que ces redondants puisque il
y a déjà un élément dans dans les
stratégies des Nations unies sur sur le
développement durable auquel le Canada
adhère une réponse qu'en étonne
plusieurs puisque de nombreux objectifs
du développement durable des Nations
Unies sont répétées dans le texte dont
il est question ici à la COP15 comme par
exemple la question de la restauration
des sols ou de la préservation des
écosystèmes ici Elisa serrer
Radio-Canada Montréal